[Music]
Valene is from berlin is very different
from where I come from I exchange the
countryside of Luxembourg for Berlin
which donggyun it was a lot more
stimulating female lights I made new
friends undefined there was a lot more
going on
feed me a female or I was young too so
that was pretty pivotal I was lucky I
didn't find it hard to stay yeah this
many Schwager finding the hits of life
Luc boy was born in Luxembourg in 1954
his parents owned a plant nursery there
he came to study horticulture in Berlin
back in 1983 and was hooked by its art
scene before long he began painting and
developing his own projects and
eventually earned a professorship at an
art academy for a few years now
Luc has also been a successful
restaurant owner the culinary success
story of Denorfia began back in 2006
with a delicatessen he opened with his
partner hiker Kush knee it offered
specialties from Luxembourg since then
it's grown into a popular place offering
bistro style food for lunch and a more
exclusive gourmet menu in the evenings
misconstrued I love I really like to
have guests just to strike up
conversations unlawful deployed to do
something nice for other people and get
feedback straight away if the people are
happy then it's great well nan-oh you
also get to know really nice people it's
a small stage of sorts that I go on
every night the Cline of Buner well
that's what's so appealing about it does
its tiny desk lights falling and that
stage is part of the artists signature
experience the former professor for
color theory chose the hues for the
furniture and interior design the walls
sport works he painted himself
[Music]
they're spaced for up to 30 guests in
demo fair the name was inspired by
Luxembourgish figure of speech about
grabbing a bite to eat
where mofo could be translated as
mouthful the front area of the
restaurant is still a delicatessen that
sells wines and other specialties from
Luxembourg essentially look some food
plays an important role in Luxembourg
both food and drink you meet up and go
out to eat if you have something to talk
about you do it over food when the wine
comes it helps solve problems or just
makes for a nice evening chicken cooked
in wine is a specialty in Luxembourg in
a small Central European country it's
generally stewed in a local vintage
often an elfling or tart Riesling at
demo fail Luc serves it with Alamut fine
cut deep fried potatoes
Luxembourg's traditional cuisine has
been heavily influenced by the
neighboring regions in northern France
as sass and Luanne it's often hearty and
rustic many dishes come from life on the
farm the Grand Duchy of Luxembourg has
more than its fair share of gourmet
restaurants twelve in the small country
sport michelin stars
[Music]
the Coco van Vita Coco van is often made
with red wine but in Luxembourg you
typically make it with Riesling I've
been told that the lighter whites were
always traditionally used for cooking
they were used to make sauces or for
stews that's a distinctive feature in
our corner of the world demo fair can be
found in the Charlottenburg district of
the German capital boeuf has lived and
worked here for years he says it's a
great place to encounter artists and
celebrities if you enjoy that kind of
thing and although it's quiet and
orderly here there's always something
going on
the restaurant has gained an excellent
reputation
including among the testers for the
gourmet your restaurant guide they've
granted it accolades for years por el
mundo fish Coco is linked mouth tippers
Felix Bush lost nazma
[Music]